I am just watching Marvel Echo and
there's a new tagline at the start this
is now a Marvel Spotlight series I'll
explain to you what that means in a
minute but what it should mean is Marvel
has remembered how the Netflix shows
were made and that they were better
that's what it should be called Marvel o
Netflix stuff that was good wasn't it
let's do that again I don't think that
would quite fit in a by line but that's
what it should be called welcome to
sidre your SciFi TV and movie channel
[Music]
so I'm watching
Echo it's very good there will be
spoilers if you haven't seen it but but
not not too much I want to talk more
about this Marvel Spotlight thing I want
to talk more about the tone and the
style of the series and but there is a
few little spoilers to
beware first of all Daredevil's in it
and he's not in the stupid red yellow
suit that he was in she hulkin he's in
the proper suit because this would be
actually before ex said earlier the
first 5 to 10 minutes of the episode is
is running through time and the
development of the character
Etc Kingpin isn't it he's very good um I
cannot wait for the new Daredevil series
and we'll talk about that in a sec as
well because I want more kingp brilliant
actor one of the best in the Marvel
Universe um I've seen people talking
about him several times and basically
saying he's a very much an actor actor
in that he other actors watch him and go
I wish I could do that he is so
terrifyingly lovable and you think he's
being sympathetic but really he's just
trying to get you to do what he
wants this character is is learns that
very quickly the hard way to be honest
that um the Kingpin is manipulative but
the actor is so good at it is so
believable he's he's one of the best
villains in all of the Marvel
but pretty much the last last 10 years
of
Marvel the tone of the series though is
very clever the makers have really use
the fact obviously that the character is
deaf so it switches from having sound to
being silent and back again but it does
it very very effectively it does it in a
way that makes
you really understand what the character
is doing but also you feel the tension
more because of that switching backwards
and forwards the emotional Road close to
the character is going through really is
emphasized by that use of sound you know
how music is used so effectively in
really good TV and movies the use of no
sound is used just as effectively in
this I'm very very impressed with this
so far the action sequences particularly
the fight scene with Daredevil is very
reminiscent of what we saw with the
Netflix deadevil series when it was at
its best they've really really made sure
that they use the sort of cutcenes
really well so they can move and have
almost you feel like it's almost one
continuous shot but if actually you know
what you're looking for you can see
where they've cut it you know they'll
there'll be something move in front of
the camera ACC cludes the uh the actors
or something things like this but but if
you didn't know that you weren't looking
for it you wouldn't know it feels like
one continuous shot and it's quite
excellent actually the way it's done the
actress that plays the echo character
really
can throw a punch she knows what she's
doing and obviously Charlie Cox back is
Daredevil we know what we're getting
from
that it is interesting though that the
Red Devil um Red Devil Daredevil reborn
series during the strikes had actually
started filming and they scrapped
filming and started again they actually
rewrote the entire series and haven't
actually started filming yet yet I don't
think now the what I was told by
somebody that is reasonably close to
this was that um basically the creators
of Daredevil were looking at what they
were doing with Eko and they looked at
what they did with
She-Hulk and there was a decision very
high up that actually they want
Daredevil to be far more like this
series than what they were doing with
She-Hulk
so when we see Daredevil
reborn we can expect that it'll be more
like this series so if you are looking
forward to the Dead reborn series and
you want to get a feel what now they're
doing with it now they've changed their
minds Christ watch this series and I
think you really will get an idea if you
have become disillusioned by Marvel in
the last few years but you loved the
stuff they did with Netflix give this
series a go because I think you might be
pleasantly
surprised it's this is Marvel back at
its best for me so far anyway they might
ruin it yet they might do some fourth
wall nonsense later and uh or whatever
God knows the problem is with Marv in
the last few years and Disney General as
a whole really is they keep seemingly
coming up with new and interesting ways
to mess things up but so far this looks
like it's going to be worth something
really interest so as I say if you've
come to Solution by Marvel give this a
try it might just reawaken your passion
for the
projects and for Daredevil as I
say not my Marvel Spotlight Marvel o
we've remembered how to do this I think
it's going to be really really good I
nearly forgot to tell you what the
Marvel Spotlight actually does mean so
it's going to be projects done by Marvel
that you don't necessarily need to have
watched everything else of Marvel to
understand so think about the infinity
Saga where you needed to watch those
movies in order to really understand and
appreciate what was going on these
series these Marvel Spotlight series are
going to be projects that in at least
some way stand on their own you don't
necessarily need to have watched
everything else before it I would argue
though for this series you really need
to have watched Daredevil or you won't
know who the hell that is and you really
need to have actually watched the um
Hawkeye series from last Christmas or
you again won't know a lot of what's
going on but it does explain enough of
it I think that you could just watch
this on its
own so guys get into comments once
you've seen the episode and tell
everyone what you think am I sort of on
the right lines with this do you agree
with me or do you think no this is more
Marvel nonsense if you've seen the
entire series I'd love to know without
too many spoilers what's going on and
how you feel about the series so get
into the comments and tell me exactly
what you think if you are new to the
channel don't forget to like subscribe H
that Bell notification it really helps
us out and you'll never miss any of our
new videos I do do Quick videos like
this and the more you know Posh videos
as well also go over to patreon.com
citre or most of our videos do Premiere
first and you get to see without the
adverts and finally go to c.co which is
our dedicated website where we do
stories based on a lot of our videos so
go check that out too as always please
stay safe and I'll see you next
[Music]
time